hey guys I'm Ryan right now I'm Jerry
we're gonna review the second trailer
the official second trailer you in
though I feel like this is the fourth
one for Furious 7 yeah I've talked
plenty about this movie oh they actually
have a legit rating prolong tremendous
sequences of violence action and mayhem
suggestive content and brief strong
someone says [ __ ] once dude wait a
minute that sounds like an awesome
[ __ ] time prologue frenetic sequences
of violence action and mayhem that is so
cool I mean I like that as these movies
get further they seem to be more and
more embracing just ridiculousness yeah
yeah that's what makes them awesome is
just how like silly and over-the-top and
committed they are to it James Wan
directing this man like you know like so
far the trailers have been showing us
yes it's gonna be as cool as the other
ones but I really want to see like
something that shows like here's all we
got a new director
most important things like so right now
hello don't wanted to your Nami your
back
this is your show
this is the special forces assassin
recruited a master
whoa
looks like the sensor from my father
this one will be in hunted Shawn lives
in a world that doesn't play by your
boots
they're not you and your friends are a
part of it now yes Graham is Pamela yes
this terminate just about fast be
curious what we do we'll be supposed to
be wrong
repins the way about small countries
this right here takes crazy to a whole
nother level
what's the plan down one last drop till
we make
out
Goody's [ __ ] sleek that
geesh
[ __ ] that film uh that looks ridiculous
that looks like why it's rated what it's
rated that looks not sane this is
another one of those weird befuddling
movies to me where i'm like this really
looks like it should be rated R for just
how much destruction and violence there
seems to be in this you know I pointed
this out the last video about Furious 7
but this trailer really just proves my
point they're really promoting a villain
this time around you know not because
they got Jason Statham who is you know a
rather well-known actor perfect for this
franchise although yes every fight scene
Jason Statham does looks like every
movie he's been before well God how come
it anytime you see Jason Statham in
these scenes are like this looks like
another Jason Statham because Jason
Statham us a ubiquitous now it's just
like cuz every time usually he shows up
you know he's gonna fight some [ __ ]
always kind of got that like with like
with that shudder to it yeah yeah they
have it in that sort of hyper age deal
there's that image Claudia were they
then make it look extra gritty and extra
like well he's a great addition because
we know Jason Statham is more than just
a buff guy who can fire a gun that's
what Vin Diesel in the rocker for he's
got a charisma about him he's got a
charisma he can do [ __ ] insane
martial arts oh yeah and he can and he
can sort of choose seen her in a wins
like not distracting yeah I mean like
the rock has wrestled likes legit
wrestling experience from my
understandings I've heard I've heard
that Dwayne Johnson was a former
wrestler of won even his real name his
real name is actually the rock oh wow
okay the Rock has wrestling experience
Jason Statham has like [ __ ] awesome
martial arts experience he's a perfect
addition to this because he's like that
[ __ ] him up kind of martial artist James
Wan with his direction I started to
actually see the difference like there's
a real light tension and suspense
actually being delivered in this time
right cuz the other ones are just fun
ass action
venture flicks one dude knows visuals
too like yeah yeah that one shot where
he likes slams him on that glass table
on the camera like rotates with them
that is a James Wan and ass shot oh yeah
a shot with this just that whole
sequence with Jason Statham in the and
the Rocco it at it looks [ __ ] amazing
there's that other shower the raucous is
walking through the street way Thank You
Kathleen up like this movie doesn't seem
like it gives a [ __ ] at all I was so
happy about that looks hardcore James
Wan seems like he really knows how to
honor that but now he's adding like real
tension you're like none of the other
Fast & Furious movies have a villain we
remember yeah they're trying they're
really promoting a villain this time
around well it makes the story more
personal right off the bat because it's
more human based now well yeah and it's
good thing they got somebody like Jason
Statham the smart choice because it's
like who's the guy was in the last one
Luke is his name Luke Evans the guy who
played Dracula yeah he was in the last
one and it's like he's still kind of
coming into the cultural consciousness
whereas Jason Statham is like oh it's
Jason Statham you'll remember that he's
there you know but not even in the last
one did they really promote the villain
but even the way he was written didn't
seem that different like I feel like
they're gonna really tailor this role of
Jason Statham mean a bad guy it's cool
because he's normally a hero you know
exactly I'm saying it seems like they're
really conscious of that and basically
being like let's make this a memorable
villain let's write a guy who certainly
seems like a force to be reckoned with
and then let's get a guy like Jason
Statham to play him big ass [ __ ] Jason
Statham even though he's smaller than
Twain Johnson like when he's like
[ __ ] up when he's like really going
at it with the rocky by it we've seen
enough Jason Statham movies and trailers
for Jason Statham movies to know that it
doesn't really matter how he is all Kurt
Russell yeah with her Russell I am
wondering if he will get more than that
one scene they keep showing from it he's
gonna be the man villain party yeah
that'd be great his last well-known role
was um stuntman like and death Proof I
just think it's cool to have him in this
now because it's [ __ ] fast
furious so there's Havanese in Kurt
Russell any time I love Kurt Russell
when I was younger like I adored Kurt
Russell [ __ ] backdraft escape from
New York thing dude Big Trouble in
Little China I love him oh no he's a
[ __ ] awesome actor dude he's my life
yeah
but Kurt Russell as a moment in the
trailer just like that this franchise
like seems like he's getting more and
more ridiculous
every time I'm happy they're doing that
because it's like it doesn't seem like
anybody has any misconceptions about
what they're doing and everyone's there
to have a good time I just don't want it
to end up like machete kills where
they're like here's more of everything
you loved yet it feels bland and empty
but I don't think this film's gonna do
that yeah like I think it seems like
they're really adding new Hollywood high
stakes to the situation well yeah I've
used this metaphor for other things
before but it's like somebody made you
like a really good pop-tart where
there's like alright what do we need
family uh crazy ass car sequences some
cool fights yeah boom there you go like
we know what it takes to make a good
movie we know what people want out of it
and we're going to do all that stuff and
then we're gonna add a cool new mystery
ingredient Jesus stay at them and then
we're gonna frost it with a little bit
of Curtis Jason Statham versus the
family you know I just hope you at one
point he punches a car in the face they
should do a crossover of The Fast and
the Furious with The Expendables and
then they should do both of that but in
space I love that shot when the bus is
flipping over and you see like that
frantic shot of Paul Walker running to
the front of the bus and because that's
the safe spot of the bus for you oh sure
there's a reason why he's running an
editor
yeah but that was a really cool shot and
like to me that's like yeah that's a
James Wong kind of thing right there oh
yeah I mean it seems like they really
let him go nuts with this you know
getting a guy with horror background
experience would obviously know how to
provide suspense and tension like the
concern for anyone would probably be
like will it be the crazy kinetic kind
of fun but it seems like he's delivering
on both this looks like nothing but
ridiculous fun
yeah and carnage but you know oh yeah
dude it's gonna be awesome car nitch all
right guys well thanks for informing me
that that trailer was out if you're new
to the channel you know what you can do
you can [ __ ] subscribe to doing real
rejects do it do it and touch yourself
and then you should check out reasons to
Jerry and touch yourself shoutouts will
continue go to facebook.com slash the
real reject shoutouts earned yourself a
shout out by saying something
interesting right now my internet is
down because 18t u-verse can go suck a
fat nut you [ __ ] it's been five
goddamn days no internet I make quick
stops - parking lots at Starbucks to
upload these videos so go to
facebook.com slash the real regis shout
outs and touch yourself